[Music]
[Music]
the invention of the metric system in
1790 improved matters somewhat by basing
units of measure a more widely agreed
upon standards like the circumference of
the earth
back at the turn of this century Lord
Kelvin namesake of the International
temperature standards at at best one has
but a poor understanding of that which
one cannot measure today we try to have
rational simple and consistent
measurement systems based on sound
scientific principles the goal of this
video series is to introduce you to the
principles of measurement but will also
show you some of the standard techniques
and equipment the series is designed as
a basic introduction to measurement it
should help you whether you are
attempting to learn about measurement is
training for a new job or you are trying
to solve a particular measurement
problem the series may not give you all
the answers but after watching I hope
that you will at least be able to ask
the right questions
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sitting up in the summit of Mount
Washington in the actual summit is
located underneath this reference datum
marker placed here by the US Geological
Survey we're gonna talk about techniques
to measure distance velocity and
acceleration using techniques as simple
as something like this ruler and as
sophisticated as this Global Positioning
System Union the fundamental standards
for the measurement of distance velocity
and acceleration are length and time
I've come here to the museum at the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology to show you a few examples of
current and historical standards of
length and time the museum is a has a
mission to preserve the historic
evolution of physical measurement now
the current standard of time is the
second and it's defined in terms of the
atomic transitions of cesium atoms
cesium atoms are part of an atomic clock
and this was one of the original cesium
ovens cesium was heated and a cesium
beam would be emitted from the front of
this oven into the atomic clock now it's
not practical to have atomic clocks for
day to day time measurement in today we
have very good working standards in
terms of quartz crystal oscillators
which are seen in things as common as my
wristwatch now the international
standard for length measurement is the
meter in the meter was established as an
international standard at the
International Conference of weights and
measures in 1889 because the US was a
member of that conference it received
one of the prototype meters which I have
here this prototype was one of 31 that
was built at that time in the one that
was closest to the existing meter was
preserved in Paris as the international
standard in each of the countries that
participated are received at least one
of these meter bars the u.s. received
number two
seven this meter bars built out of
platinum and iridium in is accurate to
within one point six microns at zero
degrees centigrade it's one point six
microns short of a true meter now this
was the u.s. standard from 1893 to 1960
in the current standard for the
measurement of length or definition of a
meter is defined in terms of the speed
of light
some historical length standards are
based on people for example this is a
replica of an Egyptian royal cubit which
was used about 1500 BC and it was based
on the length of the forearm of the
pharaoh amenhotep at MIT we also have a
unit of length which was based on a
person and we've arranged to talk to
Oliver Smoot about how this happened I
had the privilege to meet with Oliver
smooth who was a living length standard
and Ollie this said this honor is
normally reserved for kings and Pharaohs
how did how did it happen to you
well I don't know about them but I got
it because I'm short you sure I'm well I
don't know five seven I guess below
average these days okay how did they get
you to become a link standard when I was
a freshman at MIT we lived in a
fraternity house on the Boston side
Lambda Chi Alpha and you to get the
class you had to go across the mass
Avenue bridge which is a long bridge you
know exactly I'm sure and our pledge
master said he was late too often so he
wanted us within a week to measure the
bridge and he made all 14 of the
freshmen stand up and looked at us and
said Smoot you're the shortest so we'll
do it in smooth okay and how many
estimates was it across the bridge three
hundred and sixty four point four and a
near
now how did you get the point for in-ear
well actually there when we get to the
last expansion joint there's an actual
end to the bridge there it came up to
about my knees so we did point four and
[Music]
decided that since we knew there were
errors in the measure that we'd be
honest engineers and put a Greek e which
means error measurement and then we
decided that most people wouldn't know
what that meant so we wrote an ear
because maybe that's about the right
amount of error oh yeah there's a little
bridge here in the closet yes I wonder
if I could talk you into making a little
measurement of this bridge and spoons
well if it weren't for MIT being
involved in this I don't think so but
third all right this will be a credible
measurement now let's start at the edge
of the water over here okay okay okay
I'm gonna put a reference mark here at
the start of the bridge over the water
so
okay yeah let's see what you did all
right okay all right
[Music]
okay Olli we've now officially measured
the the fridge here at the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
and it looks like you're about one tenth
of a smooth short of four so we're 3.9
smooth plus or minus in here okay plus
or minus venire all right now you said
you're you're about five seven and so
one Smoot is about five feet seven
inches you think you're still five seven
is the smoothest stable reference then
maybe because my hair is this thinner I
don't know
so sometimes I guess I'll get shorter
but so far it seems to be about the same
I've come to one of the experimental
research facilities here at MIT Lincoln
Laboratory to talk about distance
velocity and acceleration measurement
the antenna you see above me is an air
traffic control radar which is used to
measure the position and velocity of
aircraft this is the radar controller
stationed at the Lincoln Laboratory
experimental radar in facility perhaps
the simplest method for measuring
distances by the use of calibrated
length scales such as this tape measure
or this ruler here now the maximum
resolution you can get with the
calibrated scale such as this ruler
depends on the minimum graduation of the
scale you can see this ruler is
calibrated both in centimeters and in
inches in the finest graduation of the
centimeter scale is one millimeter so
that this system is really only usable
for accuracy's down to say a fraction of
a millimeter
now rulers and in tape measures are good
for measuring linear distances where you
can actually put the edge you want to
measure right up against the scale so
you can get a fairly accurate
measurement of the dimension now you get
into trouble if you try to measure
something like the diameter of this pipe
with a ruler the problem is that because
you can't put the edge of the pipe right
up against the ruler
you run into what we call parallax error
if you move your head what happens is
that the apparent edge of the pipe will
move around so you can't get a very
accurate measurement now we can actually
use something like this caliper here to
measure the dimension of the pipe what I
can do let me just do it from the top
here is squeeze down on the pipe with
this caliper and you can see this is an
electronic caliper which measures the
diameter at about fifteen point nine
eight millimeters I can also flip the
calipers over and use these feelers to
measure the inside diameter of the pipe
and the caliper also has a probe here
that can be used for measuring down
inside the pipe the depth of the pipe
now I could also use something that we
call micrometer this is very commonly
used in mechanical measurements
machining and things like that
essentially what it is is a calibrated
screw what what I do is I the screw down
until it squeezes on the pipe and when
the the screw hits the pipe it stops
rotating now because I have a fair
amount of mechanical advantage twisting
the screw I need to be careful that I
actually don't deform the pipe squeeze
it so much they deform it and the way I
do that is by using this little knob
here which is a spring-loaded knob and
essentially what I do is I rotate the
screw using the spring-loaded knob and
it always applies the same amount of
torque so I essentially get the same
tension on the screw every time and it
makes the measurement repeatable now
it's common for machinist to use
something called a dial gauge here and
essentially what the dial gauge does is
I have this plunger that pushes up
against the object and it will rotate
the dial so there's a very fine
mechanism inside the gauge that will
make a measurement of the position and
and show it on this needle here and you
can see that just my jiggling around
here as I talk is causing the system to
jump
now because the mechanism is very fine
what happens is that sometimes the the
needle zero position will shift and you
can see that I can just rotate the dial
here to reserve the instrument now for
some applications you want an electrical
output rather than a mechanical output
of position and there are different ways
you can do this one common technique is
by using a potentiometer in there in
fact many potentiometers in this
oscilloscope all the knobs here are
connected to potentiometers which are
essentially just resistors and as I
rotate the position of the knob what I'm
doing is changing the value of the
resistance so you can see as I change
the position of the knob here what I'm
doing okay it's changing the resistance
which then shows up as a change in
voltage on the face the oscilloscope
here so if I change it a lot you can got
to be able to see that show up on the
scope now this is a measurement of
rotary position but I also am interested
sometimes in linear position I can also
use a potentiometer there but we can use
a technique called a linear variable
displacement transducer or LVDT now what
an LVDT is is essentially an inductor
which is in this metal core here and
inside the inductor is a magnetic
material I think this case it's nickel
which goes down inside the inductor when
it does it changes the inductance which
is measured by a circuit the circuit is
powered by the small power supply here
and is actually inside the metal tube
the output of the circuit is a voltage
in which I'm now showing in the
oscilloscope and you can see that if I
change the position of the plunger I get
an electrical output of voltage okay
if I pull the core too far out you can
see that the instrument saturates okay
so it's usable range is just a few
inches here in the middle of the motion
so far the smallest distances we
talked about measuring our thousands of
an inch or a fraction of a millimeter
sometimes you need to make measurements
more accurately and to do this you can't
really use mechanical techniques however
you can use optical techniques for
example this laser here has a if you can
see the red dot on my hand has a
wavelength of 633 nanometers which is
about 0.6 millionths of a meter and by
using interference techniques we can
make measurements on that level of
accuracy now there are many different
types of interferometers and what I want
to do is talk to you about a simple one
just to give you a feel for the concept
this is an example of a mickelson
interferometer which can accurately
measure the difference between two paths
light comes from the laser in this split
at a beam splitter into a measurement
path and a reference path the light goes
out and is reflected off of a mirror and
sent back to the beam splitter along
both paths the light is then recombined
and picked up in a detector which
measures intensity of the combined light
now if the paths are identical the waves
from the reference path and the
measurement path will be in phase and
will add together however if the paths
are different by a quarter of a
wavelength what will happen is the waves
will actually cancel they'll come back
180 degrees out of phase and cancel so
there'll be no intensity of the detector
so as the measurement path increases in
length what will happen is the intensity
measured the detector will go through a
minimums and maximums we call these
fringes and by counting the number of
fringes you can actually measure the
change in length along the measurement
path and again as you can see this can
be accurate to a fraction of a
wavelength which is very small distance
many techniques for measuring distance
use the principle of time-of-flight of
some wave to make the distance
measurement for example this ultrasonic
distance measuring unit here is used for
measuring the dimensions of rooms so
when I push this button what happens is
an ultrasonic wave is emitted from this
transducer is sent out and bounced off
the wall the reflected wave is picked up
by this second transducer over here if I
measure the round-trip time I can figure
out the distance to the wall the
distance is essentially the round-trip
time times the speed of sound divided by
two because it was the out in return
time now the measurement will be fairly
accurate if you know the speed of sound
in air now the speed of sound is about
300 meters per second however it depends
on the temperature so this measurement
will only be accurate if you are at the
temperature that the unit is calibrated
for or if you correct for changes in the
speed of sound now we actually looked at
another ultrasonic measuring unit when
we were down at the Omega engineering
labs and let's go look at that now this
is an ultrasonic distance and level
measurement system and what happens here
is that there's an ultrasonic transducer
in the top of the unit which transmits
an acoustic wave which reflects off of
the object we're trying to measure and
comes back down into the unit
the transducer actually looks something
like this
as I moved the plexiglass plate here you
can see that the distance is shorter so
it takes less time for the wave to go up
to the plexiglass and back now the
beauty of this method is that you don't
need direct contact between the sensor
and the object you're trying to measure
acoustic time-of-flight techniques can
also be used for making distance
measurements in
fluids such as water now the speed of
sound in seawater for example is much
faster than air it's about 1,500 meters
per second in these techniques are
commonly used in sonars and depth
finders on ships and submarines one of
the important distance measurements they
make on this vessel is the amount of
water under the keel now they actually
have several sensors onboard the vessel
used sonar Zoar depth finders to figure
out the distance now I'll work on
basically the same principle over here
there's a depth finder that says 22 feet
now the way they work is an acoustic
wave is sent from the bottom of the ship
down through the water it bounces off of
the bottom of the harbor and is received
by a transducer in the bottom of the
ship by knowing the speed of sound and
the water in the round-trip time we can
figure out the depth under the keel this
radar unit uses time-of-flight
techniques with radio waves
this unit has about a 10 centimeter
wavelength in four wavelengths between 1
and 30 centimeters we normally call
these microwaves now basically the way
this works is there's an antenna up in a
tower above this building which
transmits radio waves out and the radio
waves are reflected by airplanes flying
around the Boston area because the radio
waves aren't attenuated in air as
strongly as acoustic waves this
technique is good for much larger
distances also the radio waves travel
much faster so the radar here is
currently set for a range of about 60
nautical miles and it's common to use
radars and even longer distances in fact
we measure the distance between the
earth and planets using radar techniques
now so far we've only been talking about
measuring distance but you can see in
the radar plot that the radar also
measures the direction to the target we
do this by rotating the radar antenna
and let's go up to the tower and take a
look at the antenna I'm up here in the
antenna platform of this Airport
surveillance radar
and the antenna above me is spinning at
4.8 seconds per revolution now if I shut
off the antenna it'll stop we can take a
look at how the antenna actually works
now if you look closely you can see that
there are two transmitting and receive
horns at the focus of the parabolic
antenna microwaves are emitted from the
transmitting horn they go out and are
reflected off the parabola and focused
into a relatively narrow beam at a beam
width of about 1.4 degrees now the
antenna also works the other way too so
microwaves reflected off of targets will
come back and be focused into the
receive horn now you'll notice that the
antenna is wider horizontally than it is
vertically that's because for this type
of radar we actually want a narrow beam
horizontally but we actually want a
defocused or broad beam vertically so
that we get it what we call a fan beam
and that allows us to scan all altitudes
at one rotation some types of radars or
some satellite receivers actually have a
circular parabolic antenna and that
gives a very tight beam in both
horizontally and vertically what we call
a pencil beam let's now take a look at a
very basic radar display what I have
here is what we call plan position
indication display or PPI in the PPI the
antenna location is at the center of the
display and you can see the rotation of
the antenna as it rotates in what we
call it as mutual direction each of the
aircraft targets that the radar sees
shows up as a what we call blip and if
you look carefully at the blip you can
see some features that indicate the
uncertainties in the measurement if
you'll notice the targets show up wide
in the azimuthal direction but very
narrow in the range direction
what that tells you is that the range
measurement of the radar is much more
precise than the angle measurement or as
Muta measurement so the targets show up
as these sort of spread out targets in
the azimuthal direction now this simple
radar screen just shows the primary
returns from the targets and if we look
over here there's a more modern in fact
this is a research display showing some
of the other information the air traffic
controllers get now let me orient you to
the to the display here again the radar
location here is at the center of the
display and you can see range rings
here's one 10 nautical miles out from
the radar Hanscom airport is located
here right next to the radar and you can
see the runways at Hanscom if you look
down to the right you can see Boston
Logan Airport again the runway showing
is white lines and there are some light
grey lines which show you the coast in
some of the main roads around Boston now
if we look at one of the aircraft
targets you can see that there's much
more information here than just the the
blip we saw on the other radar first off
the the best estimate of the location of
the target is shown and there's some
secondary information you can see over
here now most of the aircraft flying
around Boston actually have equipment on
board to enhance their radar returns
this equipment is called a transponder
and what it does is when it receives the
radar pulse onboard the aircraft
there's a second transmitter on the
aircraft that sends a return pulse which
is much stronger than the basic
reflection that you would have from what
we call primary target now along with
that pulse the aircraft sends down some
information you can see this target here
the top line is the identification
number of the target so it's sending
down a code of five one five three and
below that identification number are
three digits which indicate the altitude
the target so this aircraft is a 2,000
feet above sea level this radar also
infers the velocity of the aircraft from
radar return so this little trail here
is essentially the last 10 hits that the
radar has had on the target so again
that's the last 48 seconds of data from
the target and by the way I should have
mentioned that frozen the the display
here so we could look at it so based on
those last 10 hits the radar has
calculated that the target is moving at
about a hundred and ten knots of ground
speed and it's moving to the west so the
air traffic controller can figure out
not only the location of the targets but
where they're moving and if there's any
problems with collisions
now radars are used for other
applications for example we can use
radars to reflect off of rain and
precipitation and if you look over here
you can see that I have a computer
output of a radar down in Florida which
happens this morning to be looking at a
a hurricane which is just hitting the
panhandle of Florida we can also use
radars on other vehicles such as ships
and let's now go down to the NOAA
research vessel albatross to look at the
radars on board that vessel this is the
radar display on the bridge of the NOAA
research vessel albatross for this is a
display of a primary radar which with
the antennas mounted on top of the
bridge here as the radar rotates it
sends out signals which are bounced off
of either ship targets or land targets
and you can give us a picture now there
the radar is actually used for two
purposes on the ship one is to navigate
and the others to avoid colliding with
other ships or boats we're now moored in
Woods Hole Massachusetts heading south
and I've set the display up here at
about a 6 nautical mile range and you
can see the
coast of Martha's Vineyard across
vineyards sound here you can also see if
you look closely in fact let me increase
the range just to display a little bit
you can see the the the black area is
the channel through Woods Hole now as I
said before we also use the radar to
avoid targets in the dots that you see
in the black are actually individual
ships or boats if I increase the range a
little bit more you can see a couple
things in the in the display first these
straight lines in front of us are
actually the jetties out in front of the
ship and you can see a few targets I
have one on the right here let me mark
it there's a little cursor and if I mark
this target you can see that there's a
boat point one seven nautical miles to
my right it's on the zero seven eight
degree bearing if we look out there well
we can see that the boat that I marked
was actually the 12 metre yacht shamrock
which is more than the harbor next to us
here at the dock we've talked about
techniques for measuring distance using
acoustic waves and radio waves but you
can also use time-of-flight techniques
with light or infrared radiation and in
fact much of the equipment that's used
for land surveying uses time-of-flight
techniques of infrared radiation now I
made arrangements with one of the
surveyors who works with MIT to show you
this equipment by measuring one of the
buildings at MIT distance measurement is
an important part of surveying in Ken
Strom who's a professional land surveyor
for kullin engineering has agreed to
help us do a survey problem here at MIT
what I'd like to do what I thought would
be fun is to try to measure the exact
height of the Great Dome here behind me
so Ken how do we have to what do we have
to do to do this well what we did was we
established a a point over here which
has a known position and we also
established an elevation on that point
by turning on it using differential
leveling techniques from a deep
benchmark
which was established in 1927 located
near the corner of this building right
behind us here okay so um we know the
height of this point and we can then
measure the difference between this
point in the top of the dome yes
utilizing our total station instrument
we can establish a difference in
elevation between the sidewalk here and
the top of the dome surveying requires a
measurement of both the distance and
direction from the known point or
reference mark to the point you're
trying to measure traditionally we would
use something like this steel tape to
measure the distance in an instrument
called a theodolite to measure the
direction of the of the distance
nowadays it's very common to use
something called a total station
instrument which combines an electronic
measurement of the distance with an
electronic measurement of the of the
angles now the way this particular unit
works is it has an infrared signal which
is emitted from these optics the
wavelength of the infrared signal is
about 0.9 microns and that wavelength is
chosen for eye safety reasons what
happens is the the infrared signal comes
out from the unit and is reflected back
by a reflector that we set at the at the
measurement point this particular
reflector here is a prism and so we
measure the distance from the instrument
to the reflector by measuring the time
it takes the infrared signal to go out
to the reflector and go back and that
round-trip time is essentially the
distance divided by the speed of light
now the speed of light and air is the
speed of light in vacuum about three
times ten to the eighth meters per
second divided by the index of
refraction of in the air and so we have
to correct for both the temperature and
pressure which influence the index of
refraction
now we the reason why we use a prism is
that we want to make sure that we have a
good signal going back to the instrument
if I use something just like a mirror
if it was misaligned I might run into a
problem so this prism is what we call a
corner cube it's if we send the light
into the corner no matter which
direction it comes from it'll go
straight back out at the instrument
that's a very common technique in fact
there are some corner cubes set up on
the moon that we use to measure the
distance between the earth and the moon
so Ken what we need to do here is find
the height of the instrument before I go
up in the dome to set up the prison so
yes as as we mentioned earlier we
established an elevation of our
reference mark with relation to mean sea
level datum and that was done via
differential leveling techniques and
we've established an elevation of ten
point zero two feet on the reference
mark and what we will do is measure up
with the ruler to an index mark on the
instrument and that'll we're measuring
five point three six feet above the
reference mark which establishes an
elevation of the instrument of fifteen
point three eight feet above mean sea
level okay I've got the prism up here I
actually had to pull it up on a line and
I set up on this tripod which is right
over the middle of the dome and what
I'll do is I'll try align it to Ken and
Ken do you have a good line-of-sight to
the prism ken do you have a good
line-of-sight to the prism all right
good
all right I'll just secure it here and
I'll be down in a minute to make the
measurement okay I think we're stable
it's pretty windy up here so we've tied
down the prism and I'll head down now
and we'll see if what the height of this
place is
okay ken now that I have the prism set
up on top of the dome ah we we need to
line up the instrument on the prism yes
that's the prism now it is in the
crosshairs okay and if we press this
angle button what we see is that the
angle of the line of sight from the
vertical which we called Zenith angle is
what 77 degrees forty four minutes and
five seconds okay and if we make the
range measurement its a slope
measurement is 693 point two one five
feet so that's the distance between the
instrument in the prism yes and the
actual height is the that distance times
the cosine of the zenith in correct
which now is one hundred forty seven
point two seven five feet before I take
down the prism I figured we might as
well take a look around while we're up
here on top of the Great Dome you can
see the green building at MIT in across
the Charles River you can see the
skyline of Boston the Hancock Tower and
the Prudential Tower and down there you
can actually see the massive bridge or
the Harvard bridge well when we had Ken
here I couldn't resist asking him to
come out to the Harbour Bridge to see if
we could see how long the bridges and
feet to compare that with smooth because
the bridge is curved we actually had to
set up the station in the middle of the
bridge and we put prisms on both ends so
Ken wants to go ahead and see if you can
measure the first prism
1,014.50 m
okay so we'll go ahead and make the
measurement here okay got it lined up
let me measure okay Ken its 1008 point
two seven feet point two seven okay so
the total length of the bridge is we had
one thousand fourteen point five three
heading towards Cambridge so the total
would be two thousand twenty two point
eight zero feet okay so and that's equal
to three three hundred and sixty four
point four smooth in and ear yes one ear
one very important type of distance
measurement is navigation or locating
your position in space now in order to
do this you need some sort of coordinate
system on the surface of the earth we
use essentially a spherical coordinate
system because the earth is
approximately in sphere now the system
we use is the latitude longitude system
zero degrees latitude is essentially the
equator and it rotates an angular
measurement from the center of the earth
up to ninety degrees at the North Pole
in ninety degrees south at the South
Pole now longitude is defined in terms
of east-west position and zero degrees
longitude is in Greenwich England very
close to London and again longitude goes
east and west from that zero position to
one hundred and eighty degrees at the
International Dateline in the middle of
the Pacific now our location here in
Boston is let's find Greenwich again
is about 70 degrees west of Greenwich
England and again about 45 degrees north
from the equator so our latitude is 45
degrees north and our longitude is about
70 degrees west now there are many
different ways we can measure position
ranging from celestial navigation
techniques where we locate our position
on the earth with regard to stars such
as the North Star or other stars in the
sky at night we can also use radio
navigation techniques where we measure
the our position with regard to radio
beacons on the earth but perhaps the
most important new technique is
something that's called the global
positioning system this is a small
global positioning system or GPS
receiver basically GPS is another
time-of-flight technique using radio
waves but the transmitters are mounted
on a constellation of satellites which
orbits the earth right now there are
about 24 satellites in the constellation
in their design such that at any one
time you should be able to see somewhere
between four and eight satellites a
computer and the receiver knows where
all the satellites should be at any one
time so by measuring the distance to
several satellites you can figure out
your location now you actually need to
measure the distance to at least four
satellites and that's because the clock
and the receiver is not as accurate as
the clocks on satellites so by making
four measurements we can resolve the
three components of position say north
east and down and also correct any
uncertainty in the receiver clock now
the accuracy of the GPS depends on the
geometry of the satellites in order to
get a good measurement you'd really like
the satellites to be spread out if all
the satellites were in the same position
you'd essentially just be making the
same measurement four times so the you
can see in this figure here if we just
look at two satellites okay if I'm a
certain range from satellite a I could
be anywhere on this line with some
uncertainty now if I measure from
satellite B I could be on this line in
my position would be in the region
covered by the intersection of the two
lines but I could be anywhere within the
intersection of the two uncertainty
bands
now if the satellites were close
together you can see the region of
uncertainty becomes much larger and this
effect is called the geometric dilution
of precision or G dot
it is normally monitored by the receiver
now if the g-dub is too large or if you
can't see enough satellites then your
receiver should warn you that your
measurement of position is unreliable
now there are other factors which can
influence the precision of the GPS
measurement in one of those is the
accuracy of the receiver now this
receiver uses what's called the civil or
CA code in most civil receivers use that
code the military uses another code
called the P code in the civil CA code
is intentionally degraded by the
military for political reasons
so that measurement will only be
accurate to within a few hundred feet
and we actually checked this by taking
this receiver up on top of the Great
Dome to measure the GPS position and
compare it with Ken surveyed position
this is a simple GPS unit so it only
uses the CA code you can see here here's
the antenna here's the unit right now
there are six satellites available to us
potentially in view the GPS have locked
up on all six satellites ok so what
we'll do is we'll now press the
navigation page and we can see that the
the GPS only thinks we're 37 feet above
sea level you'll see that drift around a
little bit as the satellites moved
however the latitude and longitude are
also displayed were 42 degrees 21
minutes 58 seconds north and 71 degrees
five minutes 53 seconds west according
to the GPS we can also see how far we
are from a reference point right now we
have Logan Airport in here in Logan
Airport is 3.58 nautical miles just
about due east of us zero eight zero
degrees so um in fact if you look at it
you'll be able to see the Tower of Logan
Airport off in the distance when I
compared the GPS measured coordinates of
the Great Dome with the survey
coordinates that Ken gave me I found
that the GPS located the Great Dome a
few hundred feet north and west of Ken's
location and most of this difference was
due to the selective availability effect
now there are ways we can correct for
selective availability in other errors
and one of these is something called
differential GPS now with differential
GPS what you do is you have another GPS
receiver at a known surveyed location
and what it does is essentially
calculates the error the current error
due to selective availability it then
transmits this correction up to the
operational GPS receiver so that you can
locate position much more accurately
basically you're just compensating out
the selective availability effect with
differential GPS it's possible to get
your position to within a few feet if
you're fairly close to the known
surveyed receiver now you can even do
better you can get accuracies as high as
a few centimeters or a few millimeters
if you use interferometric gps
techniques now we've talked about a lot
of distance measuring techniques and
what I'd like to do now is go out and
show you a simple example of a velocity
measurement technique
every time you drive a car you actually
see a velocity measurement on the
speedometer in front of you now my bike
has an odometer which actually works on
the same principle now the way most
Adamo turfs work is by counting the
number of rotations of the wheel in this
case on my bike here I have a magnetic
pickup there's a small magnet attached
to the spoke and there's a magnetic
sensor here every time the magnet goes
by the sensor it creates a little pulse
voltage pulse and that pulse is sent up
this wire to the computer unit here now
the computer unit has a quartz clock in
it and the quartz clock essentially
counts the number of pulses per second
if I know the circumference of the wheel
I can figure out what the velocity is so
for example if I spin the wheel okay you
can see that there's an indication of
pulses here and I get an indication of
velocity I can also integrate the number
of pulses and I can get a total distance
covered in fact on this ride I've gone
about 12.1 miles
I can accumulate that over time so for
example the total number of miles I've
ridden this bike is about fifteen
hundred and forty now we can measure
velocity using other techniques for
example we can measure velocity by
differentiating position measurements so
for example if we take the GPS unit in
differentiate position we can get a
velocity measurement at the 25 or 30
miles an hour I max out on my bike
there's not much risk I'm gonna get
pulled over for speeding however it's
interesting to see how police actually
measure velocity let's go take a look at
that now we're out here on Memorial
Drive in front of MIT where I've
enlisted the help of sergeant Erik
Anderson from the Massachusetts State
Police to show us some of the different
velocity measurement techniques that are
commonly used
we're gonna look at both the Doppler
radar technique and a lidar technique
this is a standard Doppler radar unit in
the way it works is by using the Doppler
effect now what the Doppler effect is is
a shift in frequency caused by the
motion a relative motion of objects and
you're maybe familiar with this if
you've ever heard a train whistle it
come at you you'll hear the tone change
as it comes at you and then goes away
you can almost hear it in some of these
cars going by the tone of the cars
changes as it goes by now the same
effect occurs with electromagnetic waves
in this unit uses a microwave with a
wavelength of about one centimeter and
that's a frequency of about 24 gigahertz
now what happens is the wave goes out
from the gun to the approaching vehicle
and is reflected off the approaching
vehicle the vehicle sees a Doppler shift
and the amount of the Doppler shift is
proportional to the velocity of the car
divided by the speed of light so what
the unit does is actually very carefully
compares the outgoing frequency to the
return frequency and then measures speed
now there is a little bit of a problem
with this unit in that it's got a fairly
wide beam the beam width is about 12
degrees so it sort of sprays out over to
the whole road that's okay because what
will what it'll do is it'll lock onto
the largest signal that's returning
that'll either be the closest vehicle or
in some cases the biggest vehicle if you
have a bus or something like that what
will happen is you'll get a large radar
return but it's a it's a very good unit
there are some other units that are used
that have actually tighter beam widths
and that's what the advantage of the
laser unit let's take a look at that now
trooper white is now utilizing the
the laser unit which is a relatively
recent speed measuring technology for
the law enforcement community we really
like it because it's officer interactive
and the width of the beam is more
specific so we're actually targeting in
on the specific vehicle without question
yeah the laser unit actually is even
though it's more modern it's it's
simpler in principle what it does is it
uses a time-of-flight technique and
makes a range measurement to the vehicle
what what you do is it sends out of
infrared pulse which goes out and
bounces off the vehicle comes back and
by knowing the speed of light in the
time it took the pulse to go out and
come back you can measure the distance
to the vehicle then what you do is you
measure the distance several times and
get an estimate of the velocity of the
vehicle you got to be a little bit
careful you can't just do it with two
pulses because you know you might first
get a hit on the front of the vehicle
and then get one on the mirror or
something like that so that would cause
an error in the measurement in what
these units do is make a lot of
measurements about 360 a second to get
an accurate measurement of the of the
velocity this gun operates at a
wavelength of 0.9 microns in the reason
it does that is for eye safety reasons
if you were to go to shorter visible
wavelengths the light actually
penetrates into the eye and could damage
the the retina and at longer wavelengths
the energy is absorbed in the outer part
of the eye and may damage the outer part
so this is actually the best frequency
to use for eye safety reasons and as you
said that the lasers have the advantage
over the radars and the fact that they
have a very tight beam with this unit
has a beam width of about two tenths of
a degree so you can really focus on a
specific vehicle whereas the radar had a
very wide beam width of 12 degrees I
would now like to talk a little bit
about the measurement of acceleration
now in principle we can measure
acceleration through the force it exerts
since force is equal to mass times
acceleration if we have a known mass we
can again figure out the acceleration
from force in most accelerometers work
on that
you can see with this spring-mass system
here I have a hundred gram mass and the
acceleration due to gravity shows me a
hundred grams on the scale if I were to
increase the acceleration if I were
basically to accelerate the system up or
let it come down let it drop I would get
a variation in the force that was read
on the scale here in fact if I were to
drop the spring scale the spring would
return to zero since I'm now in freefall
in fact you can see that this creates a
complication for us on the surface of
the earth if we want to measure
acceleration for the purposes of
figuring out what the subsequent
velocity would be because on the surface
of the earth even though this isn't
moving
it feels that 1g acceleration down the
the acceleration we feel on the earth is
a combination of the gravitational
acceleration in something that we call
the inertial acceleration and in fact
that inertial acceleration is what you
would integrate to get velocity now like
I say most accelerometers use this
principle however most accelerometers
aren't this crude I have here an example
of a piezoelectric accelerometer and
again essentially what it has is the
same sort of thing on the inside it's
got a small proof mass or test mass
inside and it has a sensor in this case
it's a piezoelectric sensor now that
piezoelectric sensor is sends a voltage
out to this amplifier and then that
amplifier brings it up to a level which
can be detected on this oscilloscope now
if I move the accelerometer up and down
you can see that the acceleration signal
shows up in the scope here now one
problem with piezoelectric
accelerometers is that they really only
measure changes in a
they're what we call AC devices you need
to use a different type of accelerometer
if you are really interested in
measuring the static or DC acceleration
another thing to notice is that this
particular accelerometer is really only
sensitive in one direction and that's
very common right now its direction of
sensitivity is up-and-down
okay so again if I move it up and down I
get a pretty good signal if I move it
left and right you can see that I don't
get too much of a signal in fact any
signal you do get is just due to the
fact that I can't move it left and right
perfectly now we talked a little bit
about integrating acceleration to get
velocity and in fact there's a
navigation principle that's based on
this this is a model of Ashley it's an
old model of an inertial navigation unit
and in principle if you have three
accelerometers one measuring say north
the yellow things here are the
accelerometers one measuring east and
one measuring down and you knew your
starting position and starting velocity
you could integrate the acceleration to
get velocity and integrate the velocity
to get position so you would be able to
navigate without ever having to make any
outside measurements and this is very
desirable for applications such as
submarines in some flight vehicles in
units like this are called inertial
navigation systems now it isn't
sufficient to just measure the
acceleration because you also have to be
able to know which direction you were
going so these three red devices here
are gyroscopes and what they do is they
measure any rotations that the vehicle
has undergone essentially in an older
system such as this gimbal based system
what would happen is that if the
platform rotated if the vehicle rotated
the gimbals would adjust and keep the
accelerometers oriented north east and
down nowadays it's more common to do
that computationally so basically all
the sensors would be fixed in what we
call a strap down in Urschel system now
one thing to think about with inertial
systems is that any errors in the
sensors either the gyros or the
accelerometers are integrated actually
two times so an error in acceleration
would be integrated once to result in an
error in velocity and that velocity
error would then be integrated in result
in an error in position so errors in
inertial systems tend to build and it's
necessary to periodically update the
both the alignment in the position of an
inertial system to cancel out those
errors we've talked about techniques for
measuring distance velocity and
acceleration ranging from simple
mechanical techniques to a variety of
time-of-flight techniques since distance
velocity and acceleration are related
quantities we can often use a technique
to measure one to infer another however
it's important to remember that distance
velocity and acceleration are vector
quantities so it's important to consider
both the magnitude and direction when
making a measurement
[Music]
[Music]